it's not adequate mal de Mer hardwired
just self-destructed ultimate nosh
[Applause]
last missile beneath chuck wood don't
scatter yeah a pair dansk your pad i
don't care dance cat now we need to
translate for the american oh yeah some
of the organs are from scandinavia so
they would understand okay so much we
will do this very to a pea task they are
extremely Danish Danish all the way
right are you are you are you I'm still
a Danish citizen I still travel on my
Danish passport but the thing is you
haven't very varied and wide taste of
music yeah I mean growing up in
Copenhagen and growing up you know my
father's and obviously mother's
household there was a very rich
tradition of a lot of jazz music Dexter
Gordon John Coltrane Charlie Parker all
that kind of stuff
but also you know Jimi Hendrix and the
Rolling Stones and my dad even listened
to a lot of classical music that was
very varied a childhood is it true that
you you knew Dexter Gordon Dexter Gordon
not only did I know him he was my
godfather he was your godfather who's
that uh um yeah Dexter Gordon um
Copenhagen in the in the 60s was sort of
like a hotbed for jazz jazz music a lot
of Americans came over Dexter Gordon Ben
Webster came and lived in Denmark and it
was a small community and my dad was
very involved in he wrote a lot about
jazz music for poutine and for Beatty
and so on and um so they got to be
friends and my dad wanted a godfather
for me that was a somewhat different so
Dexter Gordon became my god ball so your
childhood memories is like from from
smokey jazz clubs in Copenhagen ish yeah
yeah uh yeah there was a room in the
house we lived in my dad's music room
was across the hall yeah from where my
bedroom was and I have a lot of memories
from that room it's pretty smoky in
there and there was a turntable and
probably 5,000 records and always people
over and a lot of you know musicians and
journalists and kind of cool Danish
tastemakers
we're hanging out in that room and I
would spend some time and they're always
like instruments laying around like
tambourines and guitars and you know
saxophones and it was a it was an
awesome environment to grow up in and
and then he went on to start and found
Metallica yeah there was a slight detour
so the one thing we left out of this is
that even though jazz was his primary
sort of passion tennis tennis tennis
tennis is a job the day job is tennis
and so I grew up in the shadow of tennis
also and when you grow up around the
tennis circuit yeah your your your
natural path is just to follow your
father into that like football players
or whatever something I want it to be a
tennis player I imagined myself to be a
tennis player and so I spent 10 - the
first 10 15 years of my life kind of
doing that and then after I was done
with school in Denver we moved to Los
Angeles and I was gonna in Denmark I was
ranked in the top 10 in some of the age
groups when I was younger when I came to
LA I wasn't even ranked in the top 10 on
the street I lived on and uh that
severely uh that severely uh screwed me
up and so music had been kind of
bubbling under for years yeah and so
music took over when I was about 16 or
I'm the listening to to Metallica
through these all these years of your
jazz fan father gotten to to like
Metallica they did it I think he
appreciates the he appreciates metalic
especially when were daring yeah when
were little unorthodox and when we play
Strange sideways temples that I don't
even know what but our he appreciates
that side of it when we play it a little
safer and a little straighter he raises
an eyebrow yeah I saw I saw he was with
you on stage once played with you in
faith he's uh the Metallica fans will
know that he's been a fairly large
presence in and out of Metallica's
history for 35 years
there's a famous clip in the movie some
kind of monster that we did the document
10-15 years ago there's a scene where he
comes to listen to some of the stuff
were working on and you sort of see him
standing over the mixing desk and he
doesn't look too pleased and then I ask
him um I ask him what do you think of
this music and there's a long long long
pause and he goes I would delete that so
II there's uh a lot of the Metallica
fans sort of know him by association so
it's very cool
having been together as a band for 35
years
it's cruising it's crazy isn't it how
can you still stand each other
ah the worst part actually was um I
guess around 15 years ago in that movie
that was oh that the stuff that was
documented there was um after the first
20 years there were few bumps in the
road and we realized that we'd actually
never really talked to each other we'd
never really sort of spoken about how we
were feeling about what was going on we
had been so busy and things have been
moving so fast that we never slowed down
long enough to sort of take a
temperature check about how everybody
was doing so our bass player Jason left
and that was the first domino in a lot
of strange stuff that happened and for
about two years it was kind of shaken
and we were going through some issues
but on the other side of that 2003 since
then it's been fine you guys don't help
them you something we got some help yes
we got some help there was a gentleman
named Phil that came into a sort of a I
guess a calling a psychiatrist or sort
of a team mobilizer or whatever he came
in and we talked to each other and him
for about two years
you know while we were still working and
making progress and that helped us a lot
and since it's been 10 12 years now
we're all fine we talked to each other
we're civil we understand each other's
breaking points and we um have learned
it only took twenty thirty years but
we've learned to actually we've learned
to listen to each other
yeah the word
he was not double cab you Larry for the
first couple decades but it's a big part
of what we deal with now and just
hearing each other out and trying to
understand somebody else's point of view
and I also think there's a lot more um
there's a lot more trust now in each
other so we realized that we really meet
each other you know Metallica's better
as a collective than it is if it's just
you know a bunch of of autonomous single
minded guys going at it where where is
your breaking point is that if someone
criticizes you or is it my breaking
point it's very easy this is not water
this is tea and I am I'm on a steady
dose of Till's of the day so my breaking
point is impatience and I'm always so
like come on let's go let's get going
let's yeah what are we doing come on you
know and so when people are kind of uh
slouching along and all over the place
that's that sets my buttons off so it's
like listen let's hurry up and get going
hold that damn okay I'll move on I'll
move on
but oh it's so much here because it's 35
years but but but still um it has has
there been moments now in the later
years were you felt too too old for this
business too old too old Charla yeah I
would say about an hour or two ago when
I woke up you know we're in our early
50s and we still fired up to not just
eleven but twelve or thirteen and um
we're they lobbied idea dinner okay um
the main difference now obviously is
that it's like a sports team now we have
two guys that basically stretch us the
massages and it wasn't kidding I'm not I
wish I was something huh and we have um
we have a guy who sort of cooks for us
and make you know makes the healthiest
food possible and so we take anything
that has to do with the physicality of
what we do very seriously very serious
and and and so when we play these two
hour plus shows and our guys sort of
stitch us back together after the shows
a steady dose of advil and the rest of
it and all these nasty protein shakes
and all the stuff they give us that's
kind of when we feel our age but we
still I mean in terms of of the spirit
we're still young and sort of gung-ho
forward but yeah you have to be
respectful to the physicality of it
because um you know my nightmare is I'm
sitting up on stage and all of a sudden
like my arm flies off or you know that
kind of you know it's it's all you know
good we good we can do this we can
easily do this another hundred years if
the body and the physical elements of it
remain intact thank you so much lottery
Metallica Alden comedy november maria
montessori comienzo so i repeat for
control